[Applause]
[Music]
the rain didn't stop thousands marching
across tribal districts in Manipur
demanding a separate state
there's been violence and ethnic tension
since May but a video of two women from
the minority kuki Community being
sexually assaulted and paraded naked has
led to a Breaking Point
our Villages have been continuously
being attacked by the midday of groups
and killing happened every now and then
so the situation is far from uh normal
to cookie although women wear paraded
naked by the MayDay mob and were read by
the methane mobs in another cookie
District during a temporary shutdown the
writing was on the wall
the cookies say it's impossible to live
with the majority mateys after their
properties were looted and they've been
driven from their homes
metis protesters counted the cookie
demonstrations by calling for a unified
Manipur
the house for separate Homeland is
clearly so that there are foreigners
we stand for the Integrity of Manipur
and why should they asked for the
separate Homeland if they want to they
want separate Homeland then they also go
to their home where they came from
the troubles began after a court
recommended the majority mateys get the
same extended benefits enjoyed by the
minority cookies
these are tense times in this region
cookie men have traded their jobs for
Bunker positions to guard a Frontline
Village which borders a methi area we
are fighting for a course and if that
course is not met I think we are not
going to step back
we are going to
guard our land our forefather land our
ancestral land
in turn Manipur police Personnel and
paramilitary forces watch over these
farmers in metis areas
this conflict has affected our families
finances and health there's a shortage
of food children's education is
suffering after all we are all daily
wages
more than 150 people mostly minorities
have been killed and thousands displayed
since earlier this year
while curfew restrictions have been
relaxed in some areas internet ban
remains in force
Sharif Al Jazeera